hello everyone welcome to today's live
broadcast mining dense dynamic personal
data clouds to enhance health by dr.
Nathan price I never seen a jewel of lab
roots and I'll be your moderator for
today's event
today's educational seminars presented
by labrys the leading scientific social
networking website and provider of
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
this podcast is designed to be
interactive and we encourage you to ask
questions during the event you can
submit questions by typing them in the
Q&A box which can be found by clicking
on the green Q&A button at the lower
left of your presentation window we'll
try to answer as many questions as we
can you can enlarge the slide window by
clicking on the screen icon in the lower
right hand corner of the slide window
now if you have any technical problems
viewing or hearing this presentation
please click on your support button at
the top right of your presentation
window or submit your problem through
the green Q&A button in the lower left I
would now like to introduce today's
speaker dr. Nathan price dr. price is
professor and associate director of the
Institute for systems biology is be in
Seattle Washington
he is also affiliate faculty in the
department's of bioengineering computer
science and engineering and molecular
and cellular biology at the University
of Washington he is co-founder and on
the board of directors of our avail your
scientific path to wellness which was
recently named as geek wires 2016
startup of the year nathan has won
numerous awards for his scientific work
including a Howard Temin pathway to
independence award for the National
Institutes of Health a National Science
Foundation Career Award a Young
Investigator award from the Roy J Carver
Charitable Trusts
and he was named as one of the inaugural
tomorrow's pis by genome technology and
as a Camille Dreyfus teacher scholar
most recently he received the 2016 Grace
a Goldsmith award from the American
College of nutrition given to a
scientist and
the age of 54 significant achievements
in the field of nutrition for his
wording scientific notice dr. Pike price
has published over 100 peer-reviewed
scientific publications and serves on
editorial boards for many leading
scientific journals including Science
Translational Medicine and cell systems
for a more detailed biography on dr.
price please go to lab res calm and
navigate to the speakers on the
precision medicine event page I will now
turn it over to dr. Nathan price for his
presentation dr. price thank you
Christian for that kind introduction and
it's a pleasure to talk with everyone
remote remotely but hopefully I can
convey to you some of the excitement and
interest in various issues that we're
diving into here at the Institute for
systems biology so I'll start with just
the obligatory disclosures so as was
mentioned I am a co-founder of a company
called Arab ale Arab ale helped fund
import what's called 100-person wellness
project or the pioneer 100 that I'll
talk about some in this talk and I'm
also an advisor to a number of different
companies that are listed here as well
all right so this is Larry Smarr and
Larry is the head of the San Diego
supercomputing Center and most recently
he's become not the poster child let's
say but the poster man for the
quantified self movement and so Larry
has this is an iconic picture of Larry
here taken from the cover of MIT
Technology Review and about 15 years ago
Larry started making a lot of
measurements about his body so he was
one of the first people that measured in
a lot of detail and frequently their own
microbiomes monitored a lot about his
blood chemistry I gave a talk at UCSD
recently and you can go into an enormous
room with many many monitors
there that are all devoted to the
analysis of Larry's Larry's body and all
the different information that he's got
from it so what's interesting from this
is that Larry had an experience a few
years ago where he was able to look at
all of these different molecular markers
in his body and a number of things
changed really dramatically from
anything he had seen before and because
he was at UCSD and he was looking at he
has a lot of colleagues in biology and
so forth
he started to do an analysis of these
data and he came to the conclusion and
took it to his doctor and said I think
I'm getting inflammatory bowel disease
and his doctor said well how do you feel
he says well I feel fine and there's
nothing we can do to help you and he
went to a few different doctors and he
got essentially the same response and
the interesting thing here is and that's
not really a critique of the doctors
right that's just how our system is set
up we respond to symptoms we respond to
illness after something bad has happened
and not to these these data and so a few
months later Larry had an acute episode
ended up having to go to the emergency
room he got diagnosed ultimately and
sure enough he had inflammatory bowel
disease
now that's an anecdote the story could
have gone differently but it's evocative
I think of the kinds of warning signs
that may exist in our bodies before
disease arises the other really
interesting thing out of Larry's
experience is that he'd been tracking
these markers and they were quite stable
over time after it goes through this
disease incurrence
the doctors do what they do well MIT put
it past him back together again he got
better but those systems never went back
to being as stable as they were before
they're much noisier it's much more
chaotic and so what's what's interesting
is that that system then doesn't it
doesn't work quite as well as it used to
it's hard to put Humpty Dumpty back
together again in full and so this gives
us then a theory of aging this area what
happens because those systems interact
with other systems and as you accumulate
this kind of damage than it can cause
additional problems downstream so what
we wanted to do really was to take this
experience of Larry's and convert it
into take it from anecdote to science
and see how much how well would this
generalize to large numbers of people so
we have an aging population that's not
really a problem I mean we work hard to
achieve this humanity in general right
that's the whole point of clean running
water and antibiotics and vaccines and
all that that kind of good stuff
but we've achieved this and we have an
aging an aging population however a lot
was this chronic disease is also on the
rise and in fact if you look at reports
from the CDC eighty-six percent of
healthcare costs can be attributable
back to treating chronic disease today
so if we look at the determinants of
health in the United States and this is
from a 2007 New England Journal of
Medicine paper and you just look at a
person's lifetime health very roughly
speaking you can attribute approximately
30% of a person's lifetime health to
their genetics about 60% you can
attribute back to behavior and
environment and it turns out that only
about 10% of a person's lifetime health
is attributable back directly to the
healthcare system
now keep in mind that's a health care
system that and so so we we spend a lot
on that on that health care system it's
a health care system that at the moment
focuses almost entirely on care after
illness data is based on population
averages and not deeply on individual
data and we don't really know yet when
we may become chronically ill and so the
big question is what if this were
different and the really big question is
how can we make this different so in
every person's body is happening in any
particular time processes that will lead
either to greater health or to less
health or to disease
and one of the things we know is that
these probabilities of disease in the
future are can be well known but are I'm
not super motivating to people the fact
that smoking causes lung cancer didn't
effect smoking rates for a long time and
in fact it can be argued and has been in
a number of forums that that knowledge
hadn't really pushed the reduced
reducing and smoking smoking becoming
less cool and the present and society
has really driven that more according to
most studies but what you can't think
about is what can we do to understand
the processes that are happening in our
body right now that are leading to those
that you can see immediately via data
and what you really want to be able to
do then is to act on that so that you
can eliminate some of these disease
trajectories and if you're thinking
there that that's an impossible thing
that's in fact not true there are
certain there in certainly cases where
we can do this and you do this quite
routinely if you think about something
like type 2 diabetes it's very well
understood the types of behaviors that
lead one to increase dramatically risk
of type 2 diabetes and if you have a
state such as a pre-diabetic state it is
also quite straightforward to design
programs in order to back out of that
I've done that myself that's have many
many people so there's many ways that
that can be done I'll give some other
examples as we go through that
possibility so so one of the things that
we look at a lot is an area that we call
scientific wellness so I mentioned
before that only about 10% of your total
lifetime health is attributable back
directly to the healthcare system now
that's a health care system that in this
country we spend nearly four trillion
dollars a year on which is about a fifth
of GDP so it's a huge huge investment at
the same time we have a wellness
industry and there's many facets to that
wellness industry many of which are
fantastic and others in which I really
don't have I would argue a very sound
scientific basis and so in essence what
we see is the is awry
now a field that we call scientific
wellness and what's meant by this is
essentially it takes the wellness
perspective which is to try to optimize
health and minimize that chance of
disease coming down later but at the
same time that it can be based very
deeply in science in a way that's been
hard before because we just didn't have
the kind of data tools that we have now
so the the arisal of the digital health
space systems biology of the ability to
sequence genomes to get omics data to
have sensors that are more sensitive to
the body to build a learning healthcare
system where we start to harness
information from that as well all of
that really feeds into this area event
of being able to lay a data-driven
scientific framework for wellness in a
way that just hasn't been possible
before so we see this is really the rise
of a new industry so this relates also
to medicine and conceptually we use the
framework of p4 medicine that's a term
that and a definition here that was
coined by Li hood who is the president
of ISP here in Seattle and Lee's
conception here is a medicine that is
predictive preventive personalized and
participatory I think the first three
are pretty self-explanatory
a participatory really is just about
empowering people with information so
that they can make decisions that will
guide health in the best way possible
one of the ways to think about this is
if you think about your finances we
actually have huge sectors of the
economy that are set up to do financial
forecasting right and what your
financial health and what does it look
like over the course of your life
there's not exactly the same thing for
your wellness over the course of life
anyway and so there's a lot of ways to
think about this but p4 medicine breaks
down again into this notion of
quantifying wellness as well as
demystifying disease and those again are
the underpinnings of these industries
that disease industry which we would
argue is the same
the Korean healthcare industry again 97%
of costs in health care today are spent
on care after illness and then the rise
of this what we call the scientific
wellness industry so one thing I'll
argue is that we often don't study what
we most want to know when we study
health and disease and I'll use myself
as an example so I have a grant from the
NIH we study Alzheimer's disease we
study the brains of people who have
Alzheimer's and compared them to the
brains of people who don't but when do
we do that after they're dead no one's
going to give you a piece of their brain
before then and so but that's not what
we really want to understand what we
really like to know is what was
happening in the body of the person
you've got Alzheimer's disease 20 years
before that was different than the
person who didn't get Alzheimer's and
what we'd really really like to know is
if we had known about those processes
could we have intervene could we have
stopped them maybe even in fairly simple
ways and so that's what we really want
to get at now to do that you need a very
large amount of longitudinal data that's
not a novel concept already everyone you
know can appreciate the interest and
having such a large longitudinal data
set the trick is really how do you build
it and that's what I'm going to talk
about now so Lee hood and I proposed a
project called the 100k wellness project
you can see some of the publications
here and basically the hundred cape
wellness project the idea here was to
get a hundred thousand individuals do
whole genome sequencing on everybody and
then multiple times per year measure out
of the blood proteomes metabones
clinical chemistry's out of do the gut
microbiome wearable devices and
essentially build a data set that was
dense enough in terms of the amount of
information and long enough so that we
could watch outcomes so that we could
have a data set that would enable us to
go back and ask the kind of questions
that I just talked about namely to
understand the early warning signs for
all the major human
diseases so we could predict them and
prevent them to whatever extent that was
possible so that was the big vision of
this project and you're probably saying
to yourself you know if you're doing a
back of your mind kind of calculation
which certainly what I did when we were
first thinking about this this is a very
large scale to do this all you know as a
big publicly funded project what would
be something on the order of between one
and ten billion dollars pretty easily
and so so it's a very large a very large
conceived effort and it was definitely a
leap of faith I'll say when we I took
this announced this to the world that we
were going to do this at that point in
time we had raised pretty audacious I
thought some fun conversations with Lee
about that as we were pushing this
forward but what's really amazing is
that we actually think now that this is
going to scale a lot a lot bigger
actually than the initial vision that we
had and I'll explain some of the ways
that we're going about doing that so one
of those ways in essence is be a
partnership with a company that lee hood
and i co-founded with clayton Lewis
who's our CEO called era Bale and so air
Vail is taking this concept of
scientific wellness and and then what
what has been done with Arabelle is
essentially to leverage and utilize a
lot of this big biological data but to
pare it then with Wellness Coaches so
that you identify actionable
possibilities for individuals out of the
data and one of the things that's really
essential is that you can't and as we
thought about this a lot
early on you can't really just do this
huge longitudinal study we were talking
about the key is not to focus on you
know the downstream long-term effects of
what's happening with disease coming or
things like that the key is to focus on
wellness on scientific wellness and the
reason for that is that the data have
got to be meaningful they've got to have
a
impact on people's health today this
year next year the next year after that
and so forth so that people are really
getting a huge benefit by having these
data and then what you get sort of as a
side benefit is that as you get this
amount of information across a large
number of people you start to be able to
dive in and understand the early warning
signs for disease much more deeply and
then over time as you're able to make
those discoveries you can feed those
back into insights for the week all the
people that come through our program are
pioneers and so you can feed back to the
Pioneers information that's really
critical and good for their health so
anyway so Arabelle so we started this
company Arabelle and that was really a
great experience we got a lot of
wonderful people that came on board with
us and jamol highlight in particular
around behavioral coaching Jennifer Love
joy who built essentially the
forward-facing program and what the data
that was communicated back to
participants in sandy Kaplan who was are
just amazingly great wonderful wellness
coach that worked with the initial
people that came through the program and
I'll talk about that in a moment in what
we call the Pioneer 100 study and who's
now directing a coaching Arab male and
the other thing I'll mention is that we
have raised in our series a thirty nine
million dollars for the company and so
now God launched about 18 months ago
it's got about a hundred and thirty
different employees and what's really
cool is that we have now a few thousand
people have already gone through this
program and so what's really great is
that there's a partnership between Aaron
Vale and is B and so for every person
that comes to Ariel if they check a box
saying that their data can be used
anonymously for research then that
anonymized data comes in to is B we can
use it to drive scientific discovery and
we're very very grateful to the pioneers
who have come through so far and so far
95 percent of people have consented that
we're very very grateful for that we
think it's going to be really important
to the
your medicine so we're trying to build
in many different ways
scientific wellness but there's two big
integrated directions so one is I just
mentioned is Arabelle which is that
consumer facing scientific wellness
company so anyone can come in and sign
up for that pay for the program and come
through we've done about 5,000
individuals in the first 18 months and
it has a goal of transforming the
biotech industry and especially
launching this area of scientific
wellness on the other side with is be
one thing that happened that's really
important for us this last March is that
is B became an affiliate of Providence
now Providence now Providence st.
Joseph's health but the recent merger is
the third largest healthcare system in
the country and so what that does and we
hood who's our president is now the
chief science officer of the entirety of
the Providence system so what this is
doing is this is giving us a an ability
to drive changes in medicine and
multiple fronts so we're able to take
this approach to measuring lots of data
and we call these are dense dynamic
personal data clouds like explain those
in detail in a moment we can do research
to validate different metrics for
wellness how do we quantify health which
is a very challenging concept and and
how do we do that we can do research to
try to discover better assays better
ways to measure things more cheaply more
accurately programs for optimizing
wellness study wellness to disease
transitions I'll talk about a series of
clinical trials near the end of this
talk and we can study disease so its
progression its response to therapy how
it transitions to wellness and so forth
so what this does this gives us some
really powerful levers with a consumer
company that where we get an autumn eyes
data coming in from well populations as
well as an ability to dive in on
particular disease populations within
the healthcare system and with with
providence that is B is now a part of
okay so all of this really came out of a
foundational project which is what I'm
going to talk about now called the
pioneer 100 project and this and this
was a study that was led by Lee hood and
myself and basically and it's just about
to come out in publication so there will
be a publication in Nature Biotechnology
on this that will come out soon so watch
for that and so basically this was the
foundational project that led both to
the founding of Arabelle as well as to
as well as being the pilot for for this
100k wellness project idea the idea here
was just to get a finite manual set of
people so we could prototype what this
might look like so the pioneer 100 in
fact had 108 participants went up just a
little bit because we kept having people
who wanted to join the study people that
we really wanted to have a part of it
and so we let it creep up just a little
bit so I had 108 participants the age
range were varied from people in their
20s all the way to 88 plus and I say it
in that weird way because IRB doesn't
let you say people's age is over over 88
was a nine-month study in terms of our
interface with the participants
themselves IRB approved and so what do
we measure
so we measured whole genome sequencing
we did detailed blood urine saliva
measurements three times during the year
and I'll talk about those more in the
next slide we have gut microbiome again
three times continual self tracking and
lifestyle monitoring data integration
and correlations we did a lot of
analysis we had monthly coaching
sessions on actionable data we did a lot
of discovery research and we also had
immense in education so we would bring
people in and say and we do an education
event for the first 100 pioneers around
this is your microbiome what is that
what is that about what does that mean
these are blood measurements what are
what are they about what do they mean
your genome what's that what does it
mean and so forth and and a lot of these
individuals have actually continued on
in an era male so we have for some of
them quite starting to be quite long
trajectories that we can look at so in
terms of this pilot study the hundred of
the plane at 100 so again we did a whole
genome sequencing that gives us millions
of differences between every individual
just in terms of the us snips that are
there in the labs we get we did about
150 different clinical labs between
700,000 metabolites for every person I
was about the range what would come out
about 400 proteins oh link assay chips
microbial we did this is this was done
from feces so an approximation of the
gut microbiome that was again done three
times during the year and self-tracking
so this continual self tracking a
lifestyle monitoring and then you can
see at the bottom just sort of the
different what we call rounds so there's
three rounds to one or three months when
it's six months and one in nine months
so when I'm going to show differences in
time or change that's typically over a
six month period between them a three
month blood draw and a nine month blood
drop okay so what this does then this
gives us a database of actionable
possibilities that's going to grow over
time
and this creates what we call again our
dense dynamic personal data clouds okay
as I mentioned before a really huge key
to all this is to not just you know
you're not just trying to make a
prediction about something in the future
you're trying to give them actionable
information something that's useful to
them today and that's communicated to
them by a wellness coach who is
specialty is more is in the area of diet
and nutrition and behavior and then all
of this information is also reviewed by
a study physician so if we see something
that's medically actionable then that
would be referred
back into the healthcare system all
right so let's just talk very briefly
about some of the changes some of the
health impacts of this study again
remember this is basically over the
course of six months the three-month
blood drive is a nine month blood drop
and so if you look at this then one of
the first things we can do is just look
at out of range markers and this is just
based on standard clinical definitions
and so I think that makes sense to do as
a beginning because you've got to start
with what's what's accepted in the
longer-run we actually think that the
way blend Diagnostics is done is going
to change quite dramatically one of the
areas being that your genome gives a lot
of predictability about what different
analyte levels will be in the blood and
it's most likely true that there's
different optimal levels for different
people which potentially could be
predicted from the genome so that's an
area that we want to explore we think
that what Diagnostics will change pretty
pretty dramatically over the next five
to ten years but for the purposes of
this study we'll just just taking a
standard range so from this standpoint
we saw an improvement of six percent in
terms of the number of people who were
out of range based on cardiovascular
disease markers an improvement of 33% in
diabetes so I'll show that a little more
detail the next slide
inflammation improved by 12% and
nutrition by 21% so here this just
diving into the diabetes in just a
little more detail so these are the stat
the classic clinical measures hemoglobin
a1c improved by 38% fasting glucose by
19% and then insulin resistance Homa as
well as insulin levels of themselves we
saw an improvement of better than 50% in
terms of the number of people out of
range on those so that again ties into
this notion of pre-diabetes we had seven
participants who would have been
classified as being pre-diabetic who
normalized over the course of six months
over so an improvement on those types of
measures
other kind of things we measure just to
give another simple example were heavy
metal toxins here we see a person who
has elevated mercury and this person's
come out publicly so I can actually say
who they are people in the study are
productive for confidentiality so we
only mentioned publicly people who have
given their permission and who
themselves come out publicly but this
one this was endless Aska who's the Bill
Gates chair of computer science at
University of Washington and here in
this case he had elevated mercury levels
working with his coach one of the things
that was found out he really likes tuna
sushi eats it multiple times per week
for lunch and tuna is a high mercury
containing fish and so what he was able
to see was that his mercury levels had
been building up to levels that were
well beyond that recommended medically
so then all he did was he made a very
simple switch where he switched from
tuna sushi to salmon sushi cut it in
half and actually has since fully
normalized on that front so just
something that he could make an informed
decision about what he saw that what was
interesting we had two other pioneers
who went through this same process one
of them who's also coming out publicly
so I could say it was you might say well
again as a computer scientist very
involved there the other person was Jeff
bland who's actually the founder of
something called the Institute for
functional medicine has written a bunch
of books on diet so he knew all these
things but just became you know aware
like oh okay that is something happening
in my body simple choice different
another person who is in fantastic shape
really a healthy individual but we found
also elevated mercury levels for them
and for him and for him what was
interesting is that it wasn't fish for
him for him it was he had a bunch of old
fillings and his dentists apparently had
been telling him to change him for years
and that there was this possibility that
they could leach mercury but that hadn't
been motivating to him but for now they
were in fact doing that so when we made
the measure he could see that and so he
made it a change so again something that
you can see and deal with quite easily
and what was really in
incredible those are two just very
simple examples and we're going to start
wrapping up complexity here but again
it's just it just shows knowledge you
know could guide quite simple ways to go
about making decisions and so it gave a
lot of insight already even just from
those very early measurements all right
so let's talk about another one a little
more serious so here we had an
individual and he was having arthritis
arthritic like symptoms in his ankles
and needs was having quarterly to break
down and basically he has concierge
medicine on both coasts they had
apparently given him some drugs for
arthritis but it wasn't really helping
it and this was a big driver for him
because he really loves to hike with his
family and he was unable to do that
anymore because of the pain from this
condition and so anyway he comes into
our program we did this 360-degree view
and what was interesting is that
something pretty simple jumped out which
is that the ferritin levels in his blood
were very high and so because of that we
looked in its genome and he's homozygous
all right he has two copies of the gene
that encodes for the highest risk for
hemochromatosis in this case now
hemochromatosis is essentially just high
iron in the blood that's high ferritin
that you see and it turns out one of the
lesser-known side effects of
hemochromatosis is that that iron can
actually catalyze cartilage break and it
can lead to arthritic like symptoms so
anyway he because we see this has the
medical implications referred that back
into the healthcare system and then he
was diagnosed with hemochromatosis now
the treatment for hemochromatosis which
some people they know it's dead simple
you donate blood once a month donate
blood once a month gets rid of the
excess iron and that's basically it
and so he did that and after doing that
the arthritic symptoms went away he's
back to hiking with his family now it's
a Nedim one right so you we can't know
for sure
that was what you know what had the
effect but it was observed he made the
change
you got the outcome that he wanted and
so what we want to do of course is
monitor these kind of things over many
many different courses and already in
the few thousand people that have come
through Arabelle we've seen
hemochromatosis come up a number of
times as well and so that's so that's
been a really an interesting one now if
you just look at data here and remember
this small sample sizes from you know
from the hundred eight individuals so
basically if you have zero copies of the
rare variant we saw fairly low levels of
Farrington right in the normal range if
something then if people had one copy of
the gene for those 12 individuals they
did average higher levels and then for
the two individuals that had two copies
you can see they had really elevated
ferritin and that was driven by the man
that I just talked about and in his case
then what we saw was that after he's
donated the blood he did it just three
three months in a row basically that got
him down to normal now the other element
I'll just point out is that there's the
second individual that's there this is a
woman and she's premenopause and for
obvious reasons
her new macro mitosis wouldn't manifest
but what she knows now is that she's
just on alert she's got two copies of
this gene
hemochromatosis may manifest might not
if it does no big deal as long as she
monitors her ferrets and levels every
once in a while if it ever seemed an
offense donate blood and essentially
just eliminate that disease trajectory
so again empowered by knowledge to make
a simple decision that has an impact on
health it can eliminate a disease
trajectory from her life just like the
man in this study okay anyway just a few
simple examples from outcome let me talk
a little bit about data so here is a
plot each blue line here just represents
a correlation across different data
types that withstands multiple
hypothesis correction and is
statistically significant and so what's
interesting here and I just want you to
think about it for a moment is just that
these different measures and never
before been made from a population of
people and so what this does and Sara
Lee over time and so what this means is
that this is the tip of a you know just
a tiny tip of a very big iceberg but
where we start to understand okay how
are certain microbes related to certain
metabolites how are certain lifestyle
variables related to proteins in the
blood our protein blend of blood related
to clinical labs and so forth and in
fact as we're starting to do this
dynamically we're already starting to
see you know really interesting outliers
that pop out in advance of you know when
people get disease and there's just
there's many ways that this is starting
to pop up that's quite quite interesting
these two big video slides aren't going
to work and so an interest of time I'm
going to skip them but basically what
we're able to do is just take a this big
correlation network and you can break it
down in using unbiased algorithms into
modules and then each of those modules
can contain elements in them that are
familiar to us that we know how to
interpret for health but also give us
other players so in other words you
might see you know clinical markers that
matter and the microbial components in
the gut that are associated with them or
so forth so one community is the total
cholesterol community and if this video
worked it would zoom in on one of these
you could see what they look like but
I'll show any way out of this one we see
the cholesterol is very positively
associated with vitamin E one
interesting thing is that cholesterol is
negatively associated with endogenous
thyroxine the reason that's interesting
is just that there's a drug called
synthroid that's essentially is the rock
scene and it has as one of its side
effects lowering LDL cholesterol so this
got us to thinking that there are this
is potentially a very interesting path
to drug targets aren't sorry to drug
drugs themselves as well as their
targets because what you can do is you
can identify different levers of you
know what influences what in these
networks and as we have
dynamic time series data we can activate
we can build Bayesian networks and all
kinds of interesting modeling formalisms
but basically what you can start to see
are if I want to have an impact on a
particular clinical variable what are
all the different other variables that I
could push on that would have an effect
there and what we found is that a number
of those cases contain already used
drugs and they're very interesting class
of drugs because you're starting from a
compound that's natural in the body it's
already there so you know that it's safe
within certain concentration ranges
where you don't know what happens
obviously if you wrap it up a lot but
you start from a pretty good place
relative to say a screening where you're
using compounds that haven't appeared
before so that we think is quite
interesting this is the largest module
that comes out of this unbiased analysis
so this is the most interconnected part
of the measurements it's a little fuzz
out here it looks like but you can see
triglyceride swim IR HDL cholesterol
there's a number of interesting cases in
here that are really relevant to health
and in fact maybe maybe because they're
so that's a little bit chicken and egg
are they are they so densely connected
because they are the most manifesting
and health I'd say that that's probably
true but they are certainly
over-represented in the clinical labs
for exactly that reason
one interesting one here is gamma gluten
will tyrosine which is a metabolite
that's associated with GGT which is the
enzyme and basically what's interesting
there is a gamma glue channel tyrosine
just seems to be very connected to many
different aspects of health so we think
it may actually end up being a better
biomarker than than GGT that would have
to be determined so here's another view
of just a few of these a few of the
networks that come out of this and one
interesting thing that I'll point out is
if you look down near the bottom middle
of the screen you'll see cysteine
connected in green a green dot connected
to inflammatory bowel disease a yellow
dot now remember this is a
cohort so we're not talking about anyone
here that actually has inflammatory
bowel disease so what that means is it's
just the genetic risk for inflammatory
bowel disease and so what's really
fascinating I'm going to talk about this
just for a few minutes is that before
when we were thinking of this cascade of
what you know as people got diseases
we'd be able to go back and look and
find the early warning signs to try to
figure out now how to read those signals
in fact now what we're really focused on
is interpreting genetic risk for disease
and that's really powerful because it
means that every single record every
single data point is relevant to every
single disease because not everyone gets
a disease but everyone has a genetic
risk score they have a genetic risk of
genetic propensity and there's been tons
and tons of work done in the literature
so but we have a reasonable
understanding of this for you know 60 or
70 different diseases and I'm just going
to give one example here that I think is
illustrative so let's just dive in on
that cysteine example so here we find a
correlation a negative correlation very
statistically significant between
inflammatory bowel disease genetics
score and the amount of cysteine that's
in the blood now when we saw that we
then delat we then went into the
literature just to see what what was
there and a couple really interesting
papers came out so one is that there's
this and they're cited here so we got
one is that so this ulcerative colitis
activity so cysteine is was found that
the lowered cysteine it sustains the
dimer form of cysteine kind of the lower
that amount was the higher the clinical
activity index so the worse the disease
so somewhat related to that disease
process potentially and then there on
the far left you can see cysteine I was
decade' molecule we measure this was a
study done out of blood in people that
had the disease IBD and controls and it
turns out that cysteine comes up as one
of the best candidate
markers one of the biggest differences
metabolically between people that had
the disease and those who didn't so
there's a couple of really interesting
implications because remember we find
our association in a bunch of people
which nobody has the disease aged 20s
through 88 plus right so that big age
range
everyone normal and so what was really
fascinating here is that there's a
couple big implications so one is that
potentially you can imagine using these
kind of data to build correction factors
for essentially any case control study
in the world right so what do I mean by
that so if you do it your case control
study you were us anybody right you
would take a population of people as
your cases and population as controls
and you age match them and sex match
them and smash them for smoking status
or whatever made sense now it stands to
reason that the people who got the
disease at the same age those that
didn't or at higher genetic risk and
what this tells you is that there are
pre-existing differences that you expect
as a function not of the disease
manifesting but of the pre-existent
disease risk okay so that's what's being
shown here and so so you're basically
able to disambiguate what's happening
because of the onset or the existence of
the disease condition from what's there
as a precondition or precondition to
strong but is there as a as a prior
expectation and so what's what's
interesting here then it get to get to
the second big point is that potentially
by understanding how what's different
based on genetic risk you can you may be
able to understand what we call the
manifestation of genetic risk in the
body so if you think about that at a
high level genetic risk gene bearing
doesn't mean anything in a test tube
right it means something in a body and
so because of that it means that it had
it has some sort of an effect on the
system and so presumably when we do
these dense dynamic beta clouds and
answer the better but the if you have
that kind of information you should be
able to see reflections of what's
altered by this two different genetic
risk profile so in this case cysteine
and then you can map that be it on two
networks so in this case we map sis this
on to metabolic networks new plot one
really interesting hypothesis which is
that cysteine sits upstream of
glutathione pathways now glutathione is
the primary way your body combats
oxidative stress an oxidative stress is
a big trigger for IBD so pretty simple
hypothesis comes out this genotype or
whatever reason leads to lower amounts
of cysteine throughout the course of a
person's life and what that means then
is that they are marginally less well
able to deal with oxidative stresses
which means they've got a marginally
higher probability to get out of their
resilience so in transition into IBD is
a disease and so what that would mean is
that over the decades of their life they
would have a more likely chance of
getting IBD than somebody else now that
has to be proven right that's hypothesis
that comes out of this analysis but
what's really fascinating about that is
that if that's true you can imagine a
pretty simple intervention that would
change somebody from being at high risk
for IBD based on their genetics to being
at low risk for IBD because you've
intervened in the manifestation of
genetic risk so what we're talking and
whether or not in this particular
example you know holds up it is or not
the general concept I think basically
has to be true which is there has to be
some manifestation about genetic risk
and we should be able to design a
variety of approaches around most of the
major diseases that will intervene in
that manifestation of risk and so that's
really what we're trying to do around
many different disease scenarios right
now okay so as I mentioned that's just a
quick example around one case of IBD but
we can determine genetic risk for at
least 60 different diseases a number of
them are shown here is a CPC favored one
to study but basically that's we can do
this in a number
all right so where are we going so I
already mentioned I already brought up
this slide so we are exploring
possibilities both using both directions
both the individuals that are coming in
via airmail as well as in
disease-focused studies so an Arab male
one of the things that's being done is
building up a research portal that has
breath in terms of the amount of data
that that's their depth in terms of the
frequency or at the longitudinal nature
of following individual trajectories
width in terms of we have the impact of
recommendations these are individuals
were making changes in their lives so we
have we can see what happens with them
dynamically and learned from that and so
with all this what we want to do is to
build scientifically validated metrics
that we can communicate that back to the
community and back to back to our
pioneers and we want to go from 108 to
the thousands that we've got now and
ultimately we want to take this to
millions of people
so our as I said ambitions in terms of
building our data out have gone up over
time with Providence the Providence is B
affiliation this gives us some really
interesting avenues to follow so we have
now tens of millions of electronic
medical records we have an ability to
run clinical trials to interact via the
physicians with patients and just gives
us an avenue to implement p4 medicine
and scientific wellness of the type that
we're talking about now and so one of
the things we've done is to implement a
series of what we call translational
pillar projects and this is to go from
is B science to Providence clinical
practice and I'll mention just just a
couple of them here so one we have a
scientific wellness pillar and
essentially what Providence is doing is
they're putting 2,000 of their own
employees through the air mail program
and four people and doing it all under
an IRB approved study and so one of the
things that's really interesting about
that is so that data will be anonymized
but what it means is that we can do
both an economic and a health outcome
analysis of what are the benefits to the
healthcare system and what are the
benefits to the individual of undergoing
this type of scientific wellness program
and then we'll be able to ask questions
about and you get data is it
cost-effective and you know and we could
talk about that more but that's
essentially the essence of the
scientific wellness pillar there's
another pillar project that we are
pursuing right now on Alzheimer's
disease and this one we're very excited
about
so Alzheimer's disease is is an area
where that's going up in prevalence it's
it's been an intractable disease there's
been something like 270 different
clinical drug trials on Alzheimer's none
of which has been a great success and so
in essence there is a lot of work to be
done here now what we're going to do is
we're going to test two different
approaches and run a clinical trial and
one is going to be a multi drug therapy
and this will be centered at the home
which is one of the provenance hospitals
and then a second one is going to come
out of the work of a physician at UCLA
named Dale Bredesen and what Dale has
done is is build a very comprehensive
what he calls a 36 point plan it
involves pharmaceuticals brain training
exercises supplements hormone therapy is
basically a bunch of different
complicated things related to trying to
affect the process of synaptic formation
and bias that positively against its
opposite synaptic degradation and Dale
has now a program where he's taken 120
people his 120 case study
basically where he's been able to
reverse early-stage mild cognitive
impairment as well as early-stage
Alzheimer's disease and so what we want
to do is to launch a rigorous clinical
trial that will test that in a
prospective manner and so that will be
another one of these arms and it's and
it deals with a lot of the complexities
and trials because of the personalized
nature of the approach that's really
needed to drive the future of precision
medicine or of people or medicine and so
we're very excited about this and so in
essence then provenance is put in money
to help fund this trial and it will be a
chance then to apply this kind of
approaches that we're talking about here
didn't take you know with lifestyle and
molecular interventions together as well
as we'll be measuring the dentist and
have a personal data clouds across every
single one of the arms so we can
identify what's happening in these cases
we think that'll lead to stratification
and so forth so that's another big area
that we're doing going forward that's
gonna that's another major one I'm gonna
get this in the interest of time and so
here basically we have so we're expanded
context for data interpretation
integration so we are working on a
number of approaches basically to take
these data and work it through a variety
of different programs one is through
these genome scale transcriptional
regulatory networks we're not going to
say much about this as well as genome
scale metabolic networks but just to say
that it is B because we have this
background in modeling big complex
systems this is going to let us do a lot
of that data interpretation and then the
final thing that I'll say is we've also
been integrating working with a company
called multi scale Health Networks that
has really interesting ways to go about
looking at electronic health records
that we'll be working with them in order
to look at the intersection of this kind
of very deep omics data with what can be
learned from those kinds of
so again this is all focused around
building these dense dynamic personal
data clouds we think this is really the
essence of what personalized medicine is
going to be about and what precision
medicine will be and with that let me
just think the great funders we had for
the hundred personal wellness project
the Robert Wood Johnson Foundation and
the MJ Murdock Charitable Trust who have
been great partners with us and all of
this I think Lee hood who's been just
amazing for all these years that's such
a great leader through all of this and
the data got to really thank the people
who did most of the analysis and room
Aegis who's been incredible through all
this as well and with that I'm happy to
take any questions thanks thank you dr.
price for that informative presentation
now before we get started on the
question and answer session I would like
to remind our audience how to submit
questions you can submit questions by
typing them in the Q&A box which can be
found by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left of the
presentation window we'll try to answer
as many questions as we can and if we
are not able to get to your question
they will be answered via email
following the presentation okay
dr. pace our first question is what
efforts are being made to extend this
approach to a broader and more
representative population oh because a
lot of the individuals that are coming
in are coming in from arival that's you
know basically it's just whoever comes
in whoever signs out and you know and
because of the price of doing so many of
these assays it tends to be higher
socioeconomic status and so forth and so
we have a big interest in in trying to
reach out to broader population in fact
tena have been working a lot of that Lee
has gone and visited multiple times the
aboriginal tribes in Australia we got
pretty close there we got pretty far
along trying to get a
in India we're in discussions with
groups down in Mexico we tried hard made
some progress in in a rural county in
West Virginia so there are a lot of
places that we're trying to do that but
have not yet been able to quite finish
the deal on getting funding to do that
it is an area we'd love to raise
philanthropy around or else juiced or
government-sponsored studies or you know
whatever we can do but we'd love to
round out the population on the era male
side as they get those costs down I
think that that population will become
more representative as well and there
are things we can do statistically to
drive that but it's got to start
somewhere that's kind of where it's
where it's going but we think that
there's a bright future ahead in trying
to get this out to a lot more people dr.
price how do you see the changing
digital device landscape playing into
the future of scientific wellness that's
really interesting as well so so as we
look at because like current measurement
technologies are it's growing very
rapidly and so one of the challenges we
have is so as we build the dense dynamic
data clouds
you know we've received that we're going
to be changing technology platforms a
number of times and especially in the
wearable space where you can get really
high resolution information right now
you can get it's easy to get steps at
heart rate and sleep and a lot of things
but there's a lot of technologies coming
out now where you can you know use micro
needles to get you know small parameter
measures out of the blood you know
that's that's one thing that looks like
it'll it'll emerge there's very
interesting things off your phone I had
a great lunch conversation with a great
young professor out here at u-dub shweet
at Patel who has a neat way where you
could blow on you can actually just blow
on
on your phone and it can tell you
whether or not you have tuberculosis
they're using us for third world
application basically if you get these
little granulomas in your lungs and so
the sound that air makes when it has to
go around those granulomas is different
than if you don't have it so you can
actually make a diagnosis from just
listening in the sound of your breath
and so there's all kinds of things
coming out like that and so I think that
the explosion of what's going to be
possible dynamically integrate
integrating into this kind of a
framework is going to go up pretty
dramatically so we're very excited about
that now what do you think it will take
to drive broad adoption by payers to
this kind of proactive approach which is
guys jump in a little early that's
another question that we get that we get
a lot so basically right because right
now you know you know at least if people
are coming through Arabelle you know
they're they're paying for it and so
forth and what one of the things that
would be very interesting is like yeah
right when would when would an insurance
company pay for something like
scientific wellness and I think there it
really comes down to insurance companies
are you know they're very they're
conservative and they're by the numbers
right very very strongly so and so you
know the scientific Wellness pillar that
I mentioned earlier is is partly aimed
at that so if it turned out to be true
that the you know that it was cost
effective for individuals in terms of
the savings
missed eliminated disease trajectories
that that cost was greater than the cost
of the assays up front then you would
see adoption by pairs I think actually
actually occur and I think that's really
what it will take so I think you know
it's really something that's got to be
demonstrated and I know clear facts
clear unbiased ways that and I think
that's the kind of thing that would
drive
Thank You dr. price for your
presentation and for this great Q&A I'm
sorry we're out of time we're not able
to take any more questions but as a
reminder to our audience dr. price will
be answering questions via email
following the presentation dr. price do
you have any final comments for our
audience just an incredibly exciting
time in in medicine and I hope there's a
lot of young people who are listening
that involved in in this field because
there's real potential to to really
change the landscape and make big impact
and in this field right now
so anyway great love working with
everyone in this area and look forward
to hearing from some of you thank you
again to dr. Nathan price and I would
also like to thank lab groups for making
today's educational webcasts possible
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through May 23rd 2017
you will receive an email from lab roots
alerting you when this webcast will be
available for replay we invite you to
forward that announcer to your
colleagues who may have missed today's
might event now thank you for joining us
and we hope to see you next time goodbye